I'm speaking in an American art form
which is hip-hop dance seeing an image
of a fully clad was a woman with McCobb
the face veil they had job is along
abaya and then making it powerful and
beautiful that was my goal I decided to
start one Muslim don't panic
because I felt that our identity as
Muslim women we needed to stand up for
it I feel like there's a lot of
misconceptions out there among people of
other faiths about Muslim women the
dance that I do is called popping it's
one of the original hip-hop dance styles
it is gender neutral meaning that a man
or a woman can do the same moves
it creates an availability for people of
different faiths to feel open enough to
talk so people watching the stance
connecting hip-hop with the imagery it's
a very powerful thing for them and it
helps them to recognize that Muslim
women are very strong and very
independent and we choose to dress this
way